foreign
George off air you were telling me about
this article that they mentioned Dave
Ramsey and tell me yeah that's a popular
Trend John uh I think it gets more
clicks and Views so they just like to be
like I did I do something different than
Dave Ramsey and here's why I'm a genius
I'm like okay whatever so this one but
this is what's different this one is
very this is as close to sing I think
Dave Ramsey's right as you can get I
break this Dave Ramsey rule every day
and I'm starting to rethink it that is
the title of the article from Chris over
at the Motley Fool that is like when
um your husband never ever ever helps
with the laundry or dishes and his
response is
well I'm sorry that your feelings are
hurt right as like my apologies that you
have a problem right this is close man
this is almost so here's their situation
uh he says over the past few years I've
gotten into the habit of using my credit
card from nearly all expenses I've got a
prime Visa it gives me five percent cash
back on Amazon and varying levels of
cash back on other purchases at the end
of the year I have this money for cash
back rewards I put it towards Christmas
or Vacations or whatever and he says
using a credit card almost daily breaks
one of the Cardinal rules of Dave
Ramsey's debt-free living strategy he
recommends not having a card at all
while that may seem extreme I get it I
recently lost track of how much I put on
my credit card and was surprised to see
the amount and so it reminded him of how
quickly credit card balance can grow if
you're not paying attention and I don't
know if you've seen the news lately but
uh We've hit a record America where
number one at a lot of things and we've
had a Wild record of a trillion dollars
in credit card debt alone so
congratulations so he ends this article
saying looking at my card balance has
caused me to consider changing my credit
card usage so that my balance doesn't
take up any higher here's the hilarious
part John
Motley Fool makes money of course from
pushing Financial products largely debt
products and so in this article is a
pitch alert highest cashback card we've
seen now has a zero percent intro APR
until nearly 2025 and it's like if using
the wrong card could be costing you some
serious money our experts love this top
pick which fears feature zero percent
intro APR for 15 months and insane cash
back rate of up to five percent so so
hold on right right above that ad it
says it ends with this
if you're like most Americans it may be
time to take an honest look at your
credit card balance right now I did
recently and it's helped me get back on
track it may be painful at first but I
promise you'll be glad you did
here's a new credit card
I just don't I mean I get we all got to
put food on the table but this is a
funny article to put in an ad for a
credit card
I today sent a text to my manager who
said hey there's an ad um you guys are
you interested in this and I said my
Integrity is not for sale and so you do
have to put foot on the table and you
have to sleep at night and my goodness
yeah but I appreciate his honesty
realizing this person who by the way is
very financially aware he works for the
Motley Fool and is a writer on Personal
Finance topics and even he's like hey it
got out of control there for a second
guys turns out you're five percent on
Amazon is not worth the rewards because
turns out you spend more on Amazon which
means you're not winning financially by
making Jeff Bezos or whoever runs the
place any richer so uh this is a
question we get a lot John and I know a
lot of people it's the it's the biggest
hill that I will die on that other
people are like no I'm not cutting up my
card this guy's insane and I'm like
you're you're insane you're the
brainwashed one not me and I've lived
now without a credit card I cut mine up
back in 2013. I had an Amex the Delta
Sky Miles Card I was like I'm gonna game
the system bro I'm gonna get this flight
to see my family for free I had to
discover with the rotating cashback so
it was like oh restaurants five percent
this month I'm gonna go eat out more to
then game the system bro I'm gonna
really stick it to him and then I was
four thousand dollars in credit card
Tech going like
I I I'm losing and you got to check for
forty dollars right yes cash back I got
this uh message the other day someone
who was like Hey I have the Costco
credit card doesn't it make sense to use
it for the four percent on gas it's up
to seven thousand limit I'm like okay so
seven thousand four percent you're
talking like 500 bucks a year is Max if
you're spending 600 a month on gas which
very few people do and she was like yeah
I'm not going to spend that much on gas
I was like so we're gonna play this game
pretending that we're only gonna use
this Costco card for gas in order to get
300 bucks a year back I was like that's
bad math at best especially when like
we've talked about before
um I can't speak for Costco
um in fact Costco probably is not
involved in this but when it comes to
like credit card miles and stuff like
that uh flight miles
those companies aren't our friend like
like the the airline companies aren't
like you know what dude we're so happy
that you use a card with our face on it
we're not gonna give you free flights
it's not how that works
um guys like me
gain the system I use that card I rack
up miles and I get free flights and it's
that single mom who
the child support check didn't come in
and she got her hours cut because her
boss is a jerk and she has to do it to
survive and she doesn't have any money
to pay the bill the next month she's the
one with late fees that are paying my
flights and I'm not playing that game
and for those of you out there who are
going oh here goes John with this whole
single no let me read you a direct quote
from a Federal Reserve study on this we
estimate an aggregate annual
redistribution of 15 billion dollars
through credit card rewards from less to
more educated poorer to richer and high
to low minority areas widening existing
disparities
so it's reverse socialism it's the poor
are paying for the wealthies
um free stuff yes and now a lot of
people John they go well it's not my
fault John that they suck with money why
why should I not benefit from a broken
system
what do you say to that
that I refuse to participate in a free
flight
that comes at the expense of a mom being
able to take care of kids I refuse to
play that game so you're saying I would
much rather the credit card companies
um
charge single moms no late fees then
give me a free 250 flight is what I'm
saying I don't want to play that game
well what's interesting is a lot of
people also say well John it's not
coming from it's not coming from the
interest it's it's coming from the swipe
fees they charge to retailers so I dug
into this I looked at Capital One 2022
annual report turns out two-thirds of
their credit card Revenue comes from
interest fees interest fee aka the
people who are struggling yeah a third
came from swipe fees which is just
screwing retailers which then just pass
on that to you making all of your stuff
more expensive so there you go credit
card and I think I think
um uh Blockbuster is a great is a great
example if your business is built on
your customer failing
eventually your business goes away
period if the only way your business
wins is if your customer Blockbuster
didn't make their money on rentals they
made their money on late fees and that's
why they would never budge on the late
fees because that was how they made
their money they bet on their their
company survived because their customer
was failing and eventually somebody said
I'm taking that model away right if your
company is built on helping your
customer win that's longevity right so
this goes away at some point it can't
continue in the way it is yeah well I
dare all of you out there just try to
put that credit card away for 90 days
and see if it changes how you spend if
it doesn't go back to your old life but
I'm telling you it'll change how you
look at money